saving and reloading a data set
in this video we'll take a look at
saving a data set in various formats and
explore the ways to reload the saved
data
when you download a dataset the
processing scripts and data are stored
locally on your computer
the cache allows the datasets library to
avoid re-downloading or processing the
entire dataset every time you use it
now the data is stored in the form of
arrow tables whose location can be found
by accessing the dataset's cache files
attribute
in this example we've downloaded the
alisyn dataset from the huggyfacehub and
you can see that there are three arrow
files stored in the cache one for each
split
but in many cases you'll want to save
your data set in a different location or
format
as shown in the table the datasets
library provides four main functions to
achieve this
now you're probably already familiar
with the csv and json formats both of
which are great if you just want to
quickly save a small or medium sized
data set
but if your data set is huge you'll want
to save it in either the arrow or
parquet formats
arrow files are great if you plan to
reload or process the data in the near
future
while parque files are designed for long
term storage and are very space
efficient
let's take a closer look at each format
to save a data set or a dataset dict
object in the arrow format we use the
save to disk function
as you can see in this example we simply
provide the path we wish to save the
data to and the datasets library will
automatically create a directory for
each split to store the arrow table and
the metadata
since we're dealing with a dataset dict
object that has multiple splits this
information is also stored in the
dataset json file
now when we want to reload the arrow
datasets we use the load from disk
function
we simply pass the path of our dataset
directory and voila the original dataset
is recovered
if we want to save our data sets in the
csv format we use the to csv function
in this case you'll need to loop over
the splits of the datasetdict object and
save each dataset as an individual csv
file
since the 2csv function is based on the
one from pandas you can pass keyword
arguments to configure the output
in this example we've set the index
argument to none to prevent the
dataset's index column from being
included in the csv files
to reload our csv files we just then use
the familiar load dataset function
together with the csv loading script and
the data files argument which specifies
the file names associated with each
split
as you can see in this example by
providing all the splits and their file
names we've recovered the original
dataset dict object
now to save a data set in the json or
parquet formats is very similar to the
csv case
we use either the two json function for
json files or the two parquet function
for parquet once
and just like the csv case we need to
loop over the splits to save each one as
an individual file
and once our datasets are saved as json
or parquet files we can reload them
again with the appropriate script in the
load dataset function
and we just need to provide a data files
argument as before
this example shows how we can reload our
saved data sets in either format
and with that you now know how to save
your data sets in various formats